Sonntagmorgen in Melbourne Spieltag
Spitzenpartie in der untersten
australischen frauenfußball-liga es geht
um die Tabellenführung das braucht den
vollen Einsatz
ganz in Rot das f-wiment Team
Afghanistans inoffizielles Frauen
Nationalteam grätscht schießt trifft
gewinnt
[Applaus]
klingt merkwürdig aber das hier in
Melbourne ist ein Heimspiel für die
Afghanen
[Musik]
schauen sie aus Ungeduld hat ein Ende
endlich die Einwechslung endlich kann
sie zeigen was sie drauf hat dass der
Platz auf der Bank nichts für sie ist
ihre Motivation ist groß anders als die
Heimat Afghanistan ist Australien das
richtige Spielfeld nicht nur beim
Fußball
ich fühle mich hier stärker
ich kann tun was immer ich will
mal mit ich will das Beste machen aus
all diesen Möglichkeiten die sich mir
hier bieten
ich will ein aktives Mädchen sein Dinge
ausprobieren
und ich möchte damit auch eine Stimme
sein für all die Mädchen und Frauen in
Afghanistan die dort festhängt
man dann auch Uranus will alles geben es
ist wie eine Verpflichtung als läge der
Ball auf dem Elfmeterpunkt
Australien ist für Uranus und die
anderen Mädchen wie eine Großchance die
sie nicht vergeben wollen
das Leben besteht doch nicht nur daraus
stumm in der Ecke zu sitzen vor sich hin
zu vegetieren am Leben zu sein dafür
musst du doch wenigstens etwas in
Frieden lernen können ich beten du
sollst sein wer immer du sein willst sie
an was du willst das ist Freiheit in
Afghanistan haben wir jede Freiheit
verloren
sie hauen alles raus donnerstags im
Training drei Tage vor dem nächsten
Spiel hier ackern shamsia Uranus kashma
nasia das ganze afghanische
frauenfußballteam
Jeff Hopkins hat als Profi in der
englischen Premier League gespielt 16
mal für die walisische
Nationalmannschaft er ist ein erfahrener
Trainer diese Erfahrung jedoch ist neu
die Mädchen sind wirklich nachsichtig
aber mir ihre Namen zu merken und
richtig auszusprechen ich gebe mir Mühe
und liege trotzdem ständig daneben dann
lachen sie über mich aber das ist schon
okay
Stangen dribbelt sich durchs Leben
aufgewachsen in einem kleinen Dorf in
den Bergen Afghanistans kam sie mit 19
in die Hauptstadt fürs Studium und für
den Fußball
habe ich zum ersten Mal in einem
richtigen Team gespielt
direkt nach dem ersten Spiel haben sie
mich zur Nationalmannschaft geholt weil
ich so gut war und sieben Tore gemacht
habe und dann sollte ich gegen
Tadschikistan spielen aber daraus wurde
leider nichts mehr weil die Taliban
kamen
sie haben mir mein erstes Länderspiel
gestohlen my fest national Game
von klein auf hat charmsier ist geliebt
gegen den Ball zu treten mit den Jungs
aus der Nachbarschaft konnte sie mühelos
mithalten ein Mädchen behauptet den Ball
und sich selbst Scham sie ja ahnte nicht
wie wichtig dass eines Tages werden
würde jetzt weiß sie es
nur weil ich gut Fußball spielen kann
bin ich hier in Freiheit fußball ist
alles
Asyl in Australien fast die gesamte
Frauen-Nationalmannschaft Afghanistans
lebt jetzt hier Down Under weit weg von
zu Hause wo alles plötzlich unerträglich
wurde für Scham sie ja Uranus für Sie
alle
Afghanistan können nicht mehr in Frieden
leben da herrscht nur noch Traurigkeit
keiner ist glücklich das Gefühl von
Glück ist einfach nicht mehr da
hat Stress
hat Angst alle leben unter großem Druck
vor allem Frauen die so hart für ihre
Rechte gekämpft haben in den letzten
Jahren
Hals über Kopf ziehen die NATO-Truppen
ab überlassen Afghanistan und seine
Menschen den Taliban
vor allem für Frauen hieß das zurück auf
den Platz den sie zugewiesen bekamen
Freiräume wurden nicht einfach nur
kleiner sie verschwanden
als die Taliban zurückkamen haben wir
gewusst jetzt ist alles vorbei
wir Mädchen können nicht mehr vor die
Tür jede Freiheit ist weg wir können
nicht mehr zur Schule wir können nicht
mehr Fußball spielen wir sind nicht mehr
sicher weil die Kämpfe im Land jederzeit
ausbrechen könnten
nur raus aus Afghanistan viele Fasten in
den dramatischen Tagen diesen Entschluss
auch schamia
ich sah die wilden Taliban überall sie
haben Menschen geschlagen schossen um
sich verbreiteten Angst und Schrecken
ich habe mir vorgenommen das Land zu
verlassen
ich wusste nicht ob ich jemals
wiederkommen würde
ich wusste ja nicht einmal wohin ich
gehen würde
Australien ist es geworden wie ein
anderer Planet ausgerechnet Australien
sonst für seine rigorose Asylpolitik
bekannt gewährte Visa für Afghanistans
Fußballerinnen das ermöglichte die
Flucht in letzter Minute nach Melbourne
das für viele zu den lebenswertesten
Städten auf der ganzen Welt zählt das
großzügige Freiheiten bietet für
jedermann und jede Frau
Australien hier
Afghanistan da
größer kann der Kontrast kaum sein und
unterschiedlicher eine Kindheit kaum
verlaufen auch in Kabul lassen sie
Drachen steigen auch da Weg der Himmel
Sehnsüchte Träume Hoffnungen
doch im wahren Leben unter den Taliban
ist für all das kein Platz
kurz müssen die Haare sein das ist das
Wichtigste ein Haarschnitt für Jungs
eben auch wenn sanam ein Mädchen ist
aber das darf eben keiner sehen und
keiner wissen
ist jetzt 8 Jahre alt bis die Pubertät
sie eines Tages verrät soll sanam als
Junge Leben sanam wurde nicht gefragt
die Eltern haben das so für sie
entschieden
ein Mädchen das als Junge lebt so etwas
findet man in Afghanistan sonst nicht
aber wir mussten es tun weil wir so arm
sind wir haben nur Töchter keinen Sohn
der Arbeiten kann also verdient nur mein
Mann Geld also hoffen wir dass Sie uns
unterstützen kann bis sie erwachsen ist
in der patriarchanischen
frauenfeindlichen Welt der Taliban haben
missions ungleich leichter als Mädchen
um ihn zu heiß junge darf tun was
Mädchen verwehrt bleibt der Besuch der
Schule über die sechste Klasse hinaus
der religiöse Unterricht und eben vor
allem auch Arbeiten Geld verdienen
auch in der Freizeit gibt es Freiheit
für den kleinen Omid jedenfalls deutlich
mehr als es die kleine Samen je erfahren
hätte Fußball spielen unvorstellbar dass
die Taliban das eine Mädchen durchgehen
lassen würden aber ob als Omid oder
seinen Namen es macht eben einfach Spaß
doch das Versteckspiel ist gefährlich
was passiert wenn es dann am auffliegt
die Strafen der Taliban sind drakonisch
wir mussten einen Jungen aus ihr machen
Gott ist mein Zeuge wenn das die Taliban
stört dann werde ich Ihnen erklären wir
haben aus ihr einen Jungen gemacht weil
wir keine Wahl hatten
wenn Sie wollen dass die Mädchen zu
Hause bleiben dann müssen sie für uns
alle Sorgen denn wir brauchen Essen
Wasser wir brauchen Geld zum Leben sonst
verhungern unsere Kinder wir mussten
einen Jungen aus ihr machen
[Musik]
ich möchte Arzt werden oder ein
Kommandeur bei den Soldaten
oder ich arbeite bei meinem Vater
es ist bitter aber sanams Träume werden
platzen wenn sie größer wird wenn sich
Ihr wahres Geschlecht nicht mehr
verheimlichen lässt wenn sie als junge
Frau erkennbar ist dann bleibt ihr nur
der bescheidene Platz den das Taliban
regime für Sie vorsieht
es ist das Schicksal das Millionen
Frauen in Afghanistan erdulden sollen
ein Leben das keine Freiheit erlaubt
eingesperrt eingeschüchtert eingeengt
alles hat sich geändert seit die Taliban
hier wieder das Sagen haben
Afghanistan heute es gibt wohl kaum
einen anderen Platz auf der Welt der für
Mädchen aussichtsloser erscheint
Unterricht den es so nicht geben sollte
das ist eine untergrundschule irgendwo
in Afghanistan für Jungs und Mädchen
[Applaus]
dabei müsste für die schon nach der
sechsten Klasse Schluss sein
Chancengleichheit Bildungsgleichheit
nichts davon gilt im Reich der Taliban
wenn Sie sich hier heimlich treffen
verstoßen sie gegen alle Regeln wenn sie
auffliegen wird es sehr gefährlich
und trotzdem gibt es Eltern die sie
schicken und Töchter die kommen
angetrieben vom Wunsch auf Bildung mit
Hoffnungen und Träumen im Gepäck die
17-jährige Sache möchte Ärztin werden
sie erlauben Jungen bis zur 12 Klasse
die Schule zu besuchen warum dürfen wir
Mädchen unsere Schule nicht fertig
machen was ist der Unterschied zwischen
Mädchen und Jungen sind wir nicht würdig
dafür haben wir nicht das Recht eine
gute Ausbildung zu bekommen
Jungen haben immer so viel Glück und auf
uns Mädchen wird immer nur herumgetreten
Sakina unterrichtet Englisch sie ist
selbst erst 17
aus dem Nichts heraus hat sie diese
Schule organisiert den geheimen
Klassenraum die Bücher sie verdient kein
Geld das treibt sie nicht an ihr geht es
um mehr um Zukunft für alle
wir müssen lernen um unser Land
aufzubauen
ich will unser Land nicht so sehen immer
Krieg und unsere Väter haben keine
Arbeit
diese Situation ist so schwierig für uns
aber ich werde nicht aufgeben ich werde
weiter unterrichten
[Musik]
Traum war es Architekten zu werden er
ist zerplatzt wie so viele Träume von so
vielen Mädchen in Afghanistan dabei sind
sie wissbegierig fleißig neugierig wie
überall sonst auch auf der Welt
alle wollen hier Englisch lernen um ins
Ausland zu gehen
danach wollen sie wieder zurückkommen
nach Afghanistan um unser Land wieder
aufzubauen und Frieden zu haben
was für ein Schatz diese jungen Mädchen
sind ein Schatz den Afghanistan nicht
heben darf
Victoria University Melbourne Australien
11.000 Kilometer Luftlinie von Kabul
entfernt
Uranus lernt nicht im Untergrund nicht
im Verborgenen sondern offiziell
ermutigt und unterstützt vom Staat
Australien nicht Afghanistan
Englisch lernen das hat oberste
Priorität Uranus will Ankommen in der
neuen Heimat
ich möchte mich ja mit allen Menschen
unterhalten können möchte meine Freunde
verstehen all die neuen Leute in diesem
neuen Land
ich will lernen zu kommunizieren
du lernst hier vieles was in Afghanistan
für dich gar nicht möglich wäre
ja die Taliban wollen das nicht
Mädchen dürfen das nicht sie sollen
nichts lernen
ich finde das ganz schlimm mein Herz
bricht wenn ich daran denke
das ist doch schlecht für unser ganzes
Land wir könnten es doch besser haben
Australien hat seine Türen geöffnet
Scham sie und Uranus sind gekommen die
beiden sind Mitspielerinnen Freundinnen
inzwischen wie Schwestern das Leben in
der Ferne verbindet sie teilen sorgen
Hoffnungen Sehnsüchte
Einkaufen am liebsten im afghanischen
Laden um die Ecke
kochen am liebsten wie zu Hause sie
haben es mit Burger und Fritten versucht
australisch eben und landeten doch
wieder bei Knoblauch Reis Gemüse Lamm
afghanisch eben wie bei Mutter ja
zum ersten Mal gekocht habe dachte ich
vermisse dich so sehr
also wenn es eines Tages möglich ist
wieder nach Hause zu meiner Familie zu
fliegen dann mache ich mich sofort auf
den Weg
neu beginnen heißt auch alles
zurücklassen es war eine Schicksalsfrage
deren Antwort keinen Aufschub duldete
jetzt oder nie ihre Eltern haben sie
ermutigt zu gehen aber es war schwer für
alle und das ist es bis heute
mein Mann
jedes Mal wenn ich Mama Anrufe will sie
dass ich die Kamera einschalten
sie
sagt immer ich will dich sehen
so weit weg in jeder Hinsicht der Satz
klingt profan und sagt doch alles in
Australien können afghanische Frauen
noch Fußball spielen
wirklich das erste Tor des Tages gehört
ihr
Melbourne Victory der größte Club des
Landes hat dafür gesorgt dass das
afghanische Team eine Lizenz für die
unterste Liga bekam dort setzt das Team
nun Maßstäbe diesmal gibt es ein klares
acht zu eins
aber sie wollen mehr einen Platz auf der
internationalen Bühne als offizielles
Nationalteam Afghanistans der
Fußball-Weltverband tut sich schwer
der
FIFA akzeptiert das afghanische
Männerteam weiterhin und weigert sich
gleichzeitig das Frauenteam offiziell
anzuerkennen das ist absurd wenn die
FIFA Menschenrechte ernst nehmen will
diese exile Mannschaft hier anzuerkennen
wäre ein wichtiges Signal der
Unterstützung für die Rechte der Frauen
in Afghanistan
sie spielen für ein Land das nicht mehr
ihres sein darf und sie spielen mit
Erfolg fernab der Heimat
Scham sie ja macht auch das letzte Tor
des Tages gerechter Fuß ist einfach ein
Hammer sie verdankt ihn ihr Leben ein
Leben in Freiheit